sandine enters the picture loose Puck belongs
to Novak and the Predators Fabro snapshot on the
way good patch stop rebound Evangelista scores
absolutely no chance for the capitals net Miner
good Zone pressure by the Predators left side of
the screen they work it a lot of work there by
both teams offensively and defensively there's the
shot AER with traffic in front and there's that
backhand forehand little deak in front backhand
forehand shot down on one knee Luke Evangelista
five tallies as Locker indicates all of them at
even strength Sherwood on the move down the wing
fires glove save Shepard here's that shot off
the wing good speed by Sherwood letting it Fly
O'Reilly hits the brakes curls that pass trying
to find nikist that was turned aside down low
nist in tight sprawling Shephard gets the pad up
that one clangs around the frame trying to make
it two here just a few moments ago Shephard and
the post to the rescue the quarterback for the
Predators Nyquist straight away Yosi thought about
the onetime he had Edmonson in the shooting Lane
Yosi will take this one and score that's all
about lateral Movement by Yosi the Vetra and
you know he's been snake bit recently and putting
up points and goal to stay in the zone and put
more heat on the penalty killing unit here's a
lateral move getting around the Stick of Dow and
rifling it home they have struck on the power
play that's their 27th power play goal of the
year with a ton of traffic in front of Shepard
look at him looking around forsburg es scar off
gets back as the Predators clean that up Edmonson
Shake It Out wide Carlson on the way kicked out
by escaro Edmonson Fires at Point position loan
did not get the puck to cooperate and he'll have
to retreat malinin with a takeaway that pass block
and reik fires deflected rebound score Beck malen
Stein their top Trio because of hard work and
War check they get a lucky bounce right to TBR
here he directs it in front it's actually taken
away by the defense arier but it goes right off
the goal and right to manstein who started
the play and the Poke check and here's the
low shot that is looking for doubt in the
high slot Ricochet is off the defenseman
carrier off the left pad and melen Stein on a
laugh forced by carrying 5 seconds left they
Jam forward along the goal line a backhand
stop by a scar off and the rebound rolls
wide McMichael through center six
goals this season five of them at
even the other on are shorty
throw on the feet of can fir
go what a shot what a play Beautiful pass
right there protest his stroll to Obie in
the Wheelhouse and it's in and out like a rocket
ship what a pass all around on the passing play
protus stro Top Shelf one Countryman against the
other countrymen and the capitals Captain rifles
one top corner just as the penalty expir expired
here's the shot short side hits the water bottle
Tom Wilson zigzags through Center looks for
LEF nothing there according to Yosi this is
a three-on-one developing nist settles feeds
for O'Reilly great stop by shepher followup
chance goes wide yeah that's a first really
dangerous ship as scar off gets out of the
cage to sweep it away from allenstein he'll
send in forsberg to the front scolling save
miraculous stump from Hunter sheeper Hunter
sheeper entrusted with the net mining duties
and he comes up huge making it a two2 hockey
game you'd love to see them get that way to the
dressing room or perhaps Grab A Lead after
40 here's a chance Valenstein robbed there
on a night when we have seen ketov play the
wing with both oetkin and strome Tren and
advances with the wrist the clangs off the
post here it is coming right at and there's
across traffic that hits the big fella there
mcar McCaron he was cutting across hit him and
that alluded to goal tender back to Center
Off the Bench Tommy Novak Wheels in Novak
gets an angle curl and drag to the paint
at the goal line it's beneath Shephard no
goal final game on the calendar for the Cs
in 2023 a lead for yakob trenin poke check
by Shepard and he made a pad sa Shen sees
the puck bounc back to him Mo cuel kicking
it Loose there's a penalty call coming up it's
against Nashville Shepard's on his way to the
bench six attackers on in blue oetkin just
off the bench from Carlson a vkin fires he
scores joh Carlson's 500th assist sets up the
great eight worth the benchman in history to
hit the 500 assist Plateau what a sauce pass
back hand by John Carlson to send Capital One
into a frenzy Obie drills it on an oldfashioned
wrer notice the goalie no chance to see it Nick
Dow with a beautiful screen and a scorching wrer
with 59.5 to go off further review there was goer
interference therefore there and now they better
make sure they make the penalty call here O'Reilly
working laterally there's forsberg pressure
comes from oetkin forsberg gets through on
it way to the goal pad stopped Shephard rebound
doorstep still there and no goal no goal forber
forsberg once twice past Koozie then the shot the
rebound too and there's the push of his stick on
the left leg and definitely a wash out there no
goal for Nashville here in overtime referee Eric
furat right where he needed to be you see the
emphatic wash out as Carlson punches forsberg
away from the front but look at the Stick of
forsberg that's why the referee made the correct
call ketov attacking very slowly that's a
different look there fires from the outside
and thecar off makes the stick get that shot
away pushes it ahead and then tries to snap it
blocker he'll try on Hunter Shepard for size
in the shootout drifting way wide Nyquist a
slow approach fires and he scores four time
20 goal score 28 at his high and watch him
move laterally and that is under the bar
oetkin against escara straight ahead Alex
oetkin closing head fake stopped tried to go
five hole as scar off slammed the door the
Caps need a big save coming up here and yeah
he took away the five hole in a hurry didn't
he he's very limber notice how he sealed both
pads it looked like preventing that shot from
sliding Underneath Him Ryan O'Reilly will
have the first chance to win it right here
for Nashville in the bottom of the second he'll
take it wide to the boards angle in off the head
fake he snaps it home Nashville's a winner two
different looks there on those two goals Nyquist
the veteran O'Reilly the veteran get it done for
for next the former caps and the young Russian
goenda L win the backup goenda zaros here's the
two goals O'Reilly under the bar one
was glove's side one was Walker side